of course as you know our time at tbs is
coming to an end on
june 24th and i'm just curious how do
you feel about it andy
you little uh sad are you already
looking forward to the next thing
oh i'm not worrying about the next thing
i'm just savoring every minute of the
time we have left here
really oh yeah you know just focusing on
this
show huh it's funny you say that because
i
just happen to know that you updated
your skills and experiences
on your linkedin profile you follow me
on linkedin
yes i do i'd like to ask you about a few
things if you don't mind let's put this
up
here's your page look at that it says
andy richter ceo of the conan show
ceo yeah that's right ceo
comedy entertainer off to the side
well it's a bit of a stretch but how
about this one vice president of the
conan show
well yeah you're the president of the
show if you get
shot i step in as vice president and i
finish the interview with dak shepard
all right what says 1994 to 1999
you were helping the needy now that's a
lie you were already on the show andy
yeah and who was more needy than you
back then
all right okay but you got to get rid of
this one this could really get you in
trouble
member of the navy seals andy you were
never a navy seal
well it's not that kind of navy seal it
was the name of my dance troupe in
college
look oh all right well fine
but he really fluent in spanish c fluent
in italian
c fluent in french we fluent in russian
duh fluent in swedish yeah fluent in
german yeah
fluent in pig latin s.a fluent and
scottish
i fluent in pirate all right fine
what about this ego massage therapist
well i mean that's easy it's
you know what look conor i know we're in
the middle of a sketch but i just
want to seriously say that with the show
wrapping up
i'm feeling so grateful to have had the
privilege of working with you for 27
years and
i mean i i just keep coming back to this
corny phrase
comedy genius i mean that's comedy
genius it's just
it's what you are wow
thank you andy thank you so much you see
that's what an ego massage therapist is
if you're rich and insecure and you need
an ass kissing echo chamber
get the best andy richter an ego massage
for real.187
gmail.com okay i'm sorry wait a minute
what's the 187
for well there's a bunch of us going on
i mean this town is crawling with
professional self-esteem fluffers
thank you very much andy we'll take a
break we'll be right back